we're here with most highly requested
guest probably the money goes yes
everyone welcome on the podcast not real
last name that's wrong she is our guest
this week everyone welcome her hi thanks
for coming on the show
Hey nervous no I mean I think your hands
are itchy right now I think I feel itchy
to me I think you're gonna [ __ ] with me
as well you are in the same room as me
so yes
yeah this is what happened that's really
so for anyone that doesn't know Rome is
like my my number one guy my right-hand
lady Rome Mackel is a good guy Rome is
James manager math and has been for what
almost four years right I think just
rooibos is it yeah I was like to say
like we kind of jumped in her life at
the same time yeah so back off um how
are you like in a maritime feeling oh my
god how's you like in America good
enjoy yeah Rome is an American cheese
yes it is it hey no no or blue is blue
what white what do your card great red
great red card I'm holding it up T like
no I have a grain cut wrong you're from
Sydney austere from Sydney Australia and
you've lived here though for a long time
I've lived here for six years for um six
long years four glorious ones though and
then to whatever other ones yep I don't
even really remember these but Pete Pete
PJ pre Jenna you don't remember PJ
there's only happen you like move to
America why oh no you look like
is there something you need to get off
your chest I don't think so she nerves
it's okay anyway uh damnit
some room is so excited to be here yes
feels like she just walked into a trap
she's so excited and waiting for like
something we're gonna like prank you
okay it's a like it's like she's whole
thing up right yeah this actually zero
it's an elaborate three prank yeah um so
you guys do you have a question for our
guest and you want to welcome her I
welcome her night in this podcast even
even like even is this even okay so
wrong is here at our house podcasting
little boys at home yeah are you [ __ ]
with me he was texting you what oh this
texted me saying telling me what I
should do on the podcast though we
actually just talked about this before
in my life everyone your husband was
saying play [ __ ] marry kill and you were
saying you were playing that earlier
want you he asked me
[ __ ] marry kill him Eminem Eminem the
rapper and rob dyrdek from everything
yeah and I said I would kill Colin
husband ham and marry rob dyrdek I don't
see anything wrong with that and he was
upset and he was a little he was a
little upset and couldn't believe that I
was um that I was telling the truth but
I was I assured him that I would love to
kill her yeah I really would is that
party yeah it's like um my sister-in-law
sent it for when my niece came to visit
it's on my shopping list Esther is a
really efficient you can borrow that one
yeah I think I only need it when they
come to visit no one's using it okay
okay by the way just want to tell you
that along time Julian my feet just got
Oh goddamn sorry that's only want to
have a gun I should have seen you were
like digging around your pocket I should
it's weird that you were observing my
pockets a little weird I guess I'm
hypersensitive over your around this is
all Julian does in rooms around ya is
pranker you know it's kind of also your
fault because I haven't had this chance
to like get it out of my system in a
long time it's true we haven't had a
trip in what [ __ ] forever
yes playlist about this playlist it
feels I mean yeah but even then it was
like non-stop everything we didn't get
time to [ __ ] nah no I feel like you did
[ __ ] with me I [ __ ] to you I just
didn't get ample time right really right
so everything I say you start laughing
um this is what it's like for anyone
that doesn't know that when we travel
and stuff this is what it's like the
entire time
it's a [ __ ] show mmm [ __ ] yeah show yeah
I mean it's I try to just keep
everything always as professional as you
can but sometimes room just like she has
a problem with that
so we tweeted out that you're gonna be
on the podcast really aware that yeah oh
you saw I did say it did you get nervous
well some of the [ __ ] that people were
saying I was getting a little bit
nervous
what well cuz everyone told me to troll
yeah see that's cool though and can you
tell the story when someone came up to
you about knowing you from afar right
yeah no I was at Starbucks recently and
I'm like you know he the [ __ ] am i and
I'm exactly you just now here's the
kinda oh yeah I [ __ ] saw it it's uh
2025 or okay and I went up to the
counter and I was like can I get my
coffee whatever and she said oh that's
Rome right and I thought she just had
seen me there yeah and I said how do you
remember my order she said no I know you
cuz julian [ __ ] with you all the time
on snapchat oh my god so we could like
we could go on tour I could just [ __ ]
with you and that sounds no you you
already agreed okay no no
don't go back it sounds awful it sounds
great I [ __ ] hate that item
you know what if the people want it guys
via one what give the people what they
owe my god we are not recording [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
oh my god I was waiting for this at some
point Fisher no like your crew either
you're lying like I feel I'm just really
haunting about now you have to can you
like pretend like I didn't do all that
sure why you saying Charlotte is that
Emily and it started morning do you see
a red light yeah I was like wait I think
I did I thought either at some point you
were gonna say we were not recording for
you actually weren't gonna be recording
oh my oh you never big vodka like Monday
comes and then nothing comes out guys
comes out with someone else
oh man yeah ah this podcast is going to
be this coming Monday which is a week
before VidCon so if you are going to
VidCon and you're gonna meet Jenna make
sure you say how to Rome cuz she will be
there too and uh but be nice to me
yeah be nicer that's not a hundred
percent requirement bring her like a
trinket because she's new to the country
welcome god please don't don't bring me
a drink she like strength you like
trinkets everywhere I go you're going to
trinket shops I do like I want to go to
this shrinkage shrinkage shrinkage
shucks yo your your house is like
incredibly decorated serious note is
yours
that's not even a joke it's Jen you have
an absolute on fact like manner but you
know what she looks cool yeah interior
designer you do interior decoration
interior decor and you got cheated like
are huh no I'm working nope
I know um but you you started enough and
all of it
no is it what is it agree club for
interior decoration okay and then you
went right into like music the music was
they don't know I was working in
hospitality for oh you were jeweler
hospitality for a long time I've done a
mini like bars yeah I was in hospitality
so I was running bars and restaurants
for many years London hospitality the
jewelry came before London yeah so then
what I said I said jewelry first when I
was 18 I did an apprenticeship in
jewelry so I make and this was before
you moved to London yes and I um like I
worked in a jewelry store and made
jewelry I made these earrings actually
what oh my god those are like real
earrings no no they were lighting their
ear little surreal bit of like you've
been doing paper clip they're really on
your ear I mean I'm not there yeah so um
I did that for three years I didn't
finish the apprenticeship it was a
four-year apprenticeship I did the
schooling but I didn't it's a long it's
kind of you got to do four years of
school like one day a week and then
you've got to work in the trade for days
for free pretty much it's like an
internship yeah exactly
what is that for years qualify you for
and the jewelry to be a jeweler to be
euro and I kind of did it accidentally
to be on like I didn't I never wanted to
be a jeweler
it's [ __ ] me actually I'm laying
afraid job as a salesperson in a jewelry
store and they were like great you got
the apprenticeship and I was like what
that Club apprenticeship I had no idea I
was applying for an apprenticeship so I
was kind of rolled with it cuz I was 18
I thought why not and I ended up kind of
really enjoying it and doing it for I
did the schooling for four years but I
only did three years in the trade so I
never got my apprenticeship and then I
worked in bars and restaurants whilst
going to to the college to do the one
day a week of the jewelry and then after
that I went and did so in Australia it's
there's different like
how do I explain it so it is a thing
called TAFE and it's tea it's a it's a
university equivalent all right
so they do more trade stuff so I did
what they it's a it's an interior
decoration but what it is it compacts
what you would do at university where
you only write essays about the history
of iterative we did all of that but then
we also did like practical stuff where
we actually kind of decorated spaces it
was more hands-on that's really cool so
for trade stuff doing a TAFE course is
better than a university degree there's
a university degree you know what I mean
yeah so it's almost like working since
you're getting work experience us oh
yeah
and so and it's more it's just more
hands-on and it gives you yeah more of
an idea of what the job would look like
at out of college it's it's a it's a
college as opposed to like a State
University and I mean it's a State
College so I did a terrier decoration
what they did University is 20 hours a
week for four years we do 40 hours a
week for two years is being a [ __ ]
that's what she did her master yeah one
year I mean mine was not similar to a
master's degree program no I'm just
saying like it's expedited you guys
intense is fun but I I loved that but I
never really wanted to work in that so
then I worked in bars and restaurants
moved to London and then came back from
London and started working for a music
manager in Australia in Sydney and I've
worked there with him for a couple of
years loved it worked with a band called
the protectors who were like my my
little brothers I love those boys so
much and so I'm still a contact yeah
yeah and they're the sweetest guys a
super super super talented like insane
and so I love that that's when I was
like you know I want to do this on a
bigger scale I want to move to the
States so I got I got sponsored by a guy
here who managed Mazzy Star and worked
with Neil Young who we then I worked
with him for a year with Mouse
then we moved to the Santa Monica office
this is Frank jaronda yeah and that's
the crazy coincidence and he was great I
loved working with him he was really
cool he's just a funny guy and Frank
jaronda is the father of my brother's
best friend yeah which is such a small
world such a small room but you came
from basically another planet which is
Australia and then it showed up here and
we had that in common was very cool
yeah and so I worked with Frank for a
couple years and then we worked with
Neil Young for a couple of years the
last couple the last two years I worked
with him and then I met you and started
working with you but what ever since
been Len ever since we watched you
become a mom whom I was with Jenna when
I found out I was pregnant in wearing
Bob Ambala it was there - no it was the
day before because you arrived like two
days after us oh yeah I was graduating
college yeah uh so you found out before
I got there yes and we know I don't oh
you may have talked we didn't talk about
it till we were back in America see
that's what that's that yeah yeah you
really keep him weird secrets well I
didn't know she hadn't taken a pregnancy
test right you waited until you got my
words I wanted to do it with Colin yeah
but I was over there being like yo Rome
guess what time it is
Banting good thing time and Brahms like
I don't feel good yeah she was like I
think I might be pregnant I'm like no no
you know because I had just like being
your day light being your two days light
and so I don't you work he really would
yeah I know I was like there's no way it
was always pretty cool but he's adorable
right that's actually I was
she's amazing she's like next-level
adore well I don't I like I really don't
say this about other people's behaviors
a lot but damn bobbies a cube a she's
like she's I think she's pretty great
she just she I mean you're amazing
online channel like yeah like I don't I
don't ever feel like that's a very key
baby if I'm not I mean I guess we're
sort of like closer or whatever but
maybe benny-boy she's your names are all
right pipe down will get boullion here
sometimes I bring calling and boy Simon
tweeted and said just put the Bowie put
the baby on a table oh that's what they
told you were like oh honey the baby oh
that's the baby not I get a dose like
here here's bowing eyes she walks around
now you can't just put her houses yeah
we're pretty sure that she I'm trying to
figure it out for sure that she's when I
say like do you want to like a where
snaggle or you know whatever about like
looking for snaggle is wrong job job Oh
doc what um Webber face imaginary friend
called him snaggle like weird [ __ ]
name
no but we're pretty sure she says oh
[ __ ]
no I snag oh she was oh [ __ ] not what
late sounds like and even my mom on
FaceTime was like did she say oh [ __ ]
like it really it sounds like oh [ __ ]
but I'm like where would she have let
anything out [ __ ] [ __ ] goddamnit
umm yeah and I already mess it up a
really bad potty mouth um no Bowie sweet
you know but um your husband should
actually come we should have called oh
my god sister he's one of there's like a
few people who will make me cry up Greg
is one of them Greg from rhpc
Ryan's oh yeah yeah oh my god can make
me cry baby a Colin Colin is my you can
make you ask
when I met bright I was like oh my god
yeah love him because just like Colin
yeah they're so funny he's you've just
imaginary again leave and start like
they might just explode the universe
they met when you did the palms
appearance yeah but I was so brevis it
was like fine idea and everyone was kind
of like not kind of hair down relaxed
yeah we're in a command a ton of people
everywhere yeah that was DJ Mikey at the
Palms that's the name right yeah yeah
it's a nice guy he's a nice guy
yeah hi I deleted my text conversation
with him the other day because I was
trying to clear space on my phone that's
why I remember his name Wow wait you
having a text conversation no it's a
really old one from when we were texting
he texted me like after we had their
parents was like hey bro let me know if
you ever need anything at the Palms I'll
be here DJing
that's nice remember we're at the Palms
and you were pregnant and you had to be
there because of her appearance but
everyone's like looking at you why is
this our we're like staring at you
what's up yeah
people are [ __ ] rude man like we're
at work they were just assuming Rome is
like just like I didn't even want to
like put my water in - no you were
holding me and you never put your hand
on the drink I'm gonna give it to
someone yeah just like and you still
sitting there cuz people are definitely
people are funny they look at you and
they look straight down and be like like
moving their friends go she doing yeah
it's so ridiculous though like no one's
allowed to be pregnant in Las Vegas at
any given moment in time yeah or out of
the house yeah or affection in the
kitchen
hahahaha no [ __ ] you
yeah but that was um that was the trip
that the creepy song was it when you
were pregnant uh yeah I [ __ ] remember
because I nearly paid cuz I was in bed
it was like 10 o'clock watching my
friends exhausted and I was watching for
it always what I want you
yeah scary yeah you were like it's
getting creepy and all I want is
forensic it is and then I hear me finish
poem the way I know that dolphins like
dying yeah I mean I'm a man of many
talents but that was I forgot that
you're pregnant one week well because I
was that heat on you it was what was
startling about that was that it had the
metal metal trim under the door yeah
and so you put the phone up and it just
like oh it like it's like when you put
it on I was so [ __ ] loud I wish we
had that on tape oh my god
and we were just rolling around crying
laughing in the hallway yeah yeah I was
[ __ ] his Sarah [ __ ] times
yeah you know I'm proud to say that I've
only gone too far once with you do you
remember when that was how could I
forget what I could never forget I went
too far with Rome trying to prank her
once and she first first of all I knew
that this was a bad idea before I did it
did you because only because it was the
end of our trip you never [ __ ] with Rome
at the end of the trip you [ __ ] with her
in the beginning of the trip when she's
all like yeah let's go on a trip all
right so we been up we had been on I had
not slept we had to make it fine like
three hours sleep you guys didn't sleep
at all well Jenna didn't sleep at all I
had like - Jenna stayed up all night I
think maybe one hour savanna but yeah uh
yeah that was fun you got pissed I was
so [ __ ] mad yeah I wanted to punch
you in the face I felt it I liked it I
saw you know it was a night I burn you
alike and I said don't do that again
yeah cause you never looked at me like
that it said like for real yeah there's
another series yeah you turn from like
big sister room to like mom Rob yeah you
kind of act as our mom on the on the
road sometimes though I know I do you
hate it you do I don't you didn't get me
that done I didn't do it into the Mike
yeah it's a problem I was like fired I
like the smell of those things
that's another weird observation smell
it no you don't feel like our mom at all
well every we go to airport we like hand
your passports nice only happens cuz we
were [ __ ] with her and we would get
in a car and like go to the airport
exactly oh [ __ ] we forgot our passports
like that's the problem it's the boy who
cried wolf now nothing can ever go wrong
without her thinking I'm [ __ ] with
her like if I ever forget something or I
ever do something that I like need to
fix you're like oh it's a joke Julian
yeah yeah so I dug my black rat wolf mmm
I just said that did you not hear when I
said that yeah it was like maybe 1.5
seconds ago it's kind of right in the
head that was Rome's idea Julian okay
it's getting way too much got it in my
head this is the work getting a taste of
what I deal with yeah Alice I mean I see
that I do again you you get no [ __ ] you
can't joy in you get the worst angles of
me uh no I don't I don't know that I
don't um let's put a filter on it so if
you guys wanna follow me on snapchat
she's wrong Mekel okay I'm not wrong a
couple all uppercase um we want like
[ __ ] marry kill with you you can you
play with us did you prepare any God did
you come unprepared because we emailed
you about this
you didn't email me check your spam it's
probably in Spanish I said yo yeah
no you can think of whatever on the fly
but we prepared a couple [ __ ] marry kill
okay for you okay - why should we do
that sure come on first I have I haven't
known there you go that's for you what
the [ __ ] Julian what it's just a note do
you care to read it there it says darn
ugly hole that is not what I robot that
is you like me you're [ __ ] psycho
oh yeah thanks to me that it didn't say
that okay will you please read it you an
ugly hole so I need to get up and show
they camera it says you were born in
Australia Julian which I think what you
said was probably worse this is not good
you know I made fun of Australia one
time in a vlog while I was texting you
in playlist and I think I said something
along the lines of Australia stopping
along the line I got I got some nice
pretty pissed-off people the next day
yeah and then I had to say hey I like
Australia more than I like my Oh like I
want to live in Australia it's fake or
not if you're there but I'd like a
little idea so you I don't need to know
where you are
oh my god all right so you ready you
wanna go yeah ready
good she's gonna go down I even know
what this podcast is this ridiculous
Rome night my first one is different
Nicks Nick Cannon Nick Swardson and Nick
Carter killed the canary kill that's all
hey I didn't ask you
I'm just saying bro yes Watson marry cuz
yeah I'd want to keep him around because
here you funniest [ __ ] who's the
third one Nick Cannon yeah Nick Swardson
and Nick Carter Carter from the
Backstreet Boys kill um cannon kill him
and [ __ ] [ __ ] come over why do you
high-five me about [ __ ] Connor
killing your own cannon all right I got
my own Josh now Josh
Josh from Poland pilots JA from Drake
and Josh
Joshua DTV do you know all those people
I mean obviously I know Josh Josh Peck
format chart Drake and Josh Josh Peck
Julianne you must people don't know who
Josh Peck and you're not near an army
like not you know what year I was born
1943 no I know Josh Evans obviously so
this is Josh Peck he's a finer now but
he was on - oh yeah yeah yeah I do know
his face um he's a baby this is illegal
he's older than me okay okay um you know
I what who's the other one
Josh from twenty one pilots oh I don't
know twenty one pilots either Joshua
Donnie or not well way to go Julie yeah
I'm gonna go be really good one okay
she's not click [ __ ] oh so dope thank
[ __ ] me use the module I got house fire
this is the food those lit him hey hey
hey I'm calling your mom all right
do you have any idea Josh - no what what
are you doing I saw you pull one out of
your [ __ ] hooker but alright so let's
just pick another Josh what's another
Josh we can pick I don't know I'm scared
that she's gonna get up there you're
gonna shoot it joke it all that's right
here okay hi I'm done okay let's just do
[ __ ] marry kill Josh Evans Drake and
Josh
Joshua Jackson big Oh Joshua Jackson
that seemed every time your age group
Joshua Jackson hmm I would marry him
because I want to keep him around he's
pretty awesome pretty great um well I'd
say killed one I don't know and [ __ ]
Josh Evans
Wow inappropriate okay next Wow he's
married watch out for this one
sorry alright my next one is uh some
white rappers okay we got only a white
rapper Eminem
Macklemore and riffraff I would not like
I don't know nobody tell Macklemore I
hate review it killed knocking I know
but I can't clamor hating the most so
you got the [ __ ]
riff-raff because you're obviously
marrying Eminem yup yeah yeah
so you're the [ __ ] riffraff well I mean
only because I have to with or without
his Lincoln are you come around with if
I'm gonna I want to go the reference no
wait isn't he Jodi high-roller yeah the
thing yeah refract right you right yeah
Jodi high-roller okay matter look at
Batman anyone you want Ryan Reynolds rob
dyrdek [ __ ] marry kill my [ __ ] a game
Rob Jack I would marry because he is so
funny that I just want to keep him
around you like him I didn't anywhere
close my mind though cuz we met Rob
Dyrdek and you like kept it together
that whole time I didn't know and I
spoke to him on the phone knows like I
heard the conversation actually to
organize is a damn fine yes and when
when we met if he was like yeah I
remember you you're the Australian and I
couldn't [ __ ] believe it
you're [ __ ] I was gonna say that yeah
are you lady I just think he's really
funny and great he is funny we were
actually watching ridiculousness the
other day and I was like this would be
such a boring show like that wasn't yeah
him yeah he's so really leaving here is
that show yeah I know the room so when
we were taping it I mean that's he's
it's after top dead instantly but he
comes up with these gems yeah how the
[ __ ] is it incredibly smoking yeah while
we were there he was like yeah you know
he came back and was like just you know
do whatever relax its the easiest show
ever and I'm like you're probably one of
the only people that would say that like
he can go in there and just like say rob
dyrdek things and how that be his shirt
like five episodes of die
yes
Roundy yeah but I mean you want to
answer my question oh my god Ryan
Reynolds Batman um
kill Batman [ __ ] Ryan Reynolds which
Batman are and killing though oh so
you're killing all I got so yeah you're
doing is you're killing the dreams of
all these young boys who look up to
Batman sorry
his parents are dead and now he's dead
are you happy my parents are dead oh my
god Julian staring down the barrel of
the gun don't do that Ian it's just a
popper guys don't point it at people
this is actually made in Australia no we
won't do that our head Oh
oh my god get you damn it Oh
Podcast I probably screamed really hard
- it's on your head Julian oh sorry
hope you're staying around to help clean
up last night racing right to complain
of the mess you made alright so [ __ ]
Ryan Reynolds religion Alok a Jenner
you're ten okay he's great
do I get to you can ask me any are we
gonna ask anyone else but wrong or just
asking wrong you can answer it but would
you rob dyrdek rekkles Batman in my
mouth ah [ __ ] bagman [ __ ] Batman there
and kill rob dyrdek yeah you're [ __ ]
dead to me I'd kill him while he was
recording since I'd walk onto the set
and be like hey it's my genre unreal
unreal is a great show good it isn't it
Joe music yes it's so do you know those
so really [ __ ] with the Batchelor
that's what has I had an effect well no
no they [ __ ] with it is in it it is an
hour before the bachelorettes
so calculated so you're watching unreal
going oh my god you know all of that
shortly more coming every works yours
you watch The Bachelorette you're like
100% the producers put that person up to
that Oh like it really does the most
like can't really go too much at a time
on it later by Torian is it does unreal
mm-hmm I feels like a ballsy move for
lifetime I agree to use it I feel like
the yeah lead in position I know it's an
incredible shop yeah
it's solely well done and that the
characters Rachel is so great yeah she's
go love her she's good [ __ ] double
yeah and I got into it too late but I
watched the first season that the second
half of the first season I watched just
before the second season aired so we
binge watch the whole first season I
need you I need to stop the very
beginning I'm still like totally like
into it and I missed half yeah it's
really good yeah oh you got to watch the
first half when does the SEC like second
seasons on right now yeah Monday so we
watched all of season one and then we
watched the finale and now see season
two is I think it just do it was episode
two last week oh we have two episodes
that exist that we can watch it's really
great I'm dying I want to watch it all
right Julian Wow
nothing all right I got some some sexy
magicians for you I love magician David
Copperfield David Blaine
Criss Angel [ __ ] marry kill can I kill
all of them if you kill all of them you
cannot [ __ ] or marry anyone for the rest
of your lives happily if it came down to
those three no savage David Copperfield
David Blaine Christine okay Chris angels
dead hate that guy
giant star I hate Criss Angel
Copperfield I would marry because keep
him around over mmm bleh bleh um are you
and your husband David Copperfield gonna
invite us over for dinner yet
I want to see his house my turn
sometimes I'll need a way for a response
for me because I know it's not coming
back
it's not coming alright can I ask this
one what
no I already brought it it's it's it was
mine hmmm there's no kill in this one
there's no kill it's just [ __ ] Mary
God monkey and sagol Oh which our rumps
two dogs we put this I already know the
answer
who would you [ __ ] and who would you
marry and [ __ ] monkey I called it the
Fox Nagaland Mary Mary a monkey I'm not
even gay I'm not even gonna explain my
rationale no it's gonna sound like
monkeys madam you guys probably think
we're so [ __ ] up which we're not our
podcast we make the rose we're not like
that okay
Oh Ryan Higa Greg Oh
to real we know these people rob dyrdek
why would you throw out this I don't
know I don't [ __ ] know why don't you
just not ask me why I would do it Oh
I mean I love all of them well the great
thing about this game is you can have
your true self so just remember next
time we see Ryan and Greg they're gonna
have lost this because I'm gonna send it
to them at the time stamp okay I feel
like I've married Rob Dyrdek a bunch so
he can just kill him what you are
welcome Colin we go down right get rid
of the video um and I would um [ __ ] Ryan
marry Greg I think talk a little more
about that no no
I wanna grow a little bit uncomfortable
that's done you gonna kill me like
nightmare fuel how it's here your hand
right now
did you say I was literally just the
seed after you exploded that finger face
or hands are gonna be itchy I don't act
like you didn't enjoy though it's like
serious when your feet when my feet get
it yeah I'll make your feet pretty edgy
don't act like you're not enjoying this
whole thing what this this when I scare
her and all the other things that I need
shoot her in the face Jim or what no why
are you shorts oh [ __ ] why I'm sitting
in a chair no sanitary shirts are riding
up look at you like this yeah make sure
you like that so you don't see this I
was doing a video you watch okay you're
from Australia you watch rugby an Aussie
Rules Football this is [ __ ] I'm not
used to saying your upper thighs sorry
again you're welcome I have great upper
thighs shojai frankly I think it's a
little [ __ ] annoying that you looked
at my leg I mean there you go doing just
snatch on my legs
yep cool fam I didn't ask that it was
cool so what's your favorite day of the
week
like all-time hunter
she's got nothing Saturday okay and on
Saturdays deeper purple blue just like
the papal okay
weird combo right new in the bond with
the next echo what the [ __ ] alright I'm
getting it hold on it's like I was
snapchatting your upper thighs mmm
alright these are food people okay
Gordon Ramsay Oh Wolfgang Puck guy feel
good kill die Fieri
I hate him guys here kill Guy Fieri
[ __ ]
I marry Gordon Ramsay and [ __ ] em gang
hmm I don't marry Gordon Gordon is age
70
I'll be right hell yeah that would be a
ride oh you said that I would marry
Gordon renter yeah okay so we were you
see the show hotel that's he's one yeah
have you ever seen it it's like yeah he
basically goes to get some nightmares
for her do we watch season one like
whenever it came out dear - yeah um and
it was like super goofy like Hotel no
look cheesy like just like Hell's
Kitchen and we were like we love Gwen
Ramsay but we don't watch it and then
the other day they completely revamped
it it's like production values there
it's beautiful
and it's like a totally different show
complete tan yeah I used to enjoy
editing I used to watch that when I
lived in the UK and it used to like it
was airing live not live life but you
know what I mean like this around that
time and I used to thoroughly I think
anything that Gordon Ramsay does is good
he's he's very talented and then you've
eaten at his restaurant here haven't you
you did for your baby I took her her
birthday like years that he was your
first birthday that we spent together
yeah I took you to that was which is we
were all living in the west side that's
right
yeah oh we were all living on the west
side uh-huh follow me I'll move diagram
book that [ __ ] valleys dope about the
valley I know I remember when you moved
to the valley and I'm like you're crazy
and then I'm like a year later I'm like
valleys [ __ ] dumb valleys right it's
pretty awesome yeah it's not like he
doesn't really go an hour to go a mile
yeah seriously time
that's my last [ __ ] marry kill 300 dress
you had a bunch I do are they gonna be
people that Rome knows does it does can
we have personal friends or Jeff Probst
Tom Cochran uh uh robbed it I'm just
kidding Mark Zuckerberg
Oh God Zuckerberg can choice [ __ ] Probst
and Mary Cochran you oh that's a good
choice I was gonna say you wouldn't
marry prosper then I forgot ya talkin no
I want cuz Mike I mean am i right in
saying that my theory is the Mary is the
guy like the person that you want to
spend like yeah you can just like shag
so I want to get rid of them right Mary
and the lies that you also have to sweet
joy and B but then right when they're
grumpy and hungry and that's just you
that's so weird that though that right
on P and hungry yeah it's like you live
with the person you see bad sides of
them how is that weird why are you
calling me out on my own podcast I don't
like it
would you ever move back to London maybe
like tomorrow's them um that's it like I
want to go to London Sunday can you tell
me what it's like a cold okay can you
tell me more what it's like like it's
great I love lemon it's like on the top
of my list I really wanna go to London
is an incredible City
that is clouds clad they joke that they
joke that you can hit your head on the
clouds as you like and leave their house
and if it soggy sometimes yes love foggy
weather it's so cool like and summer in
London is so [ __ ] great because
everyone like people lay out on their
window sills invocate like people do
anything to be in sunshine cuz they
never get it yeah so all the little
parks in all the small neighborhoods are
just rammed full of people having
picnics and playing frisbee and it's
just like a really cool City and then
like the tube is great and being able to
just walk everywhere and ever there are
a lot of like really old buildings to
the architecture there is so stunning
yeah I just saw onto the street and all
the streets are you know what only in
Boston who is yeah not that I know but
from what I hear and it's just like
winding little streets cobblestone
streets when I can kind of like discover
you can walk the streets for hours and
never see the same looking yeah
Dublin I kind of felt like it just so
bad yeah yeah yeah but that's where they
caused Dublin that how long did you
think I was after three years three
years is that like from Australia to UK
like a pretty normal
like transitions looked a lot of Aussies
been there yes yeah yeah because um the
the visa probably like to get a visa to
come here was really really difficult
but who wears to go to the UK at these
they just give you a two-year these are
like you don't know some questions but
um but the transition is hard because
the lifestyle is really different it's
really metropolitan whereas Sydney is
more like like Santa Monica
yeah its laid-back be that's really you
know there's [ __ ] pie face and my
eyes only do my swords no qvb TV babe
until next time dan I want to go back to
what was that place called
Keiko's [ __ ] he goes so first off they
have the best like it's a little
breakfast shop yeah so men um well um
you need big collabs or any projects
coming up that weekend yeah I'm gonna
have a big collabs
okay um there is one game that I wanted
to oh you have material oh [ __ ] your
headphone haha
yeah but that's I figured you hear did
you turn your headphones off
no but I can hear turn monden there on I
just certainly ma'am yeah you have been
able to hear this entire time I'm gonna
hear what it sounds like it's raw
I can still you've been listening like
this I could still hear oh my god
listen I'm listening listen okay um okay
so I have some Aussie words oh [ __ ] that
I don't believe that you would know oh
[ __ ] so there's just a couple it's about
to go down so they're all kind of like
end in Aussie if you so where are we
competing right now me and Julian p.m.
yes sir you should okay it's a time step
point what's the time thing
take a turn guys I don't want to beat
her in a buzzer man no sticky chicken
tourists yeah okay
oh no you say whatever you think it is
first okay this is it right first
something okay pause II
what does posi mean hmm it means that uh
you got an every she does that thing
which is mmm it means you pregnant so
it's a Kazi on your [ __ ] pregnancy
test claps that point year posi it's a
purse both wrong
- oh yeah who's closer james time movers
but it not not in your meaning balloon
the actual word hello position posi so
like what so is in coming here yeah or
like hurry up we're gonna get in line i
don't want to get a good policy and you
want to get a good posi in the queue
yeah oh the kid pee and the a new band
name pausing the queue called it okay
next one don't pause these with you mazi
woo mazi mm-hmm um mozzie alright I
think it means like hutzpah like that
guy's got an awful lot of mozzie over
there it's getting like Rousey
yeah but mozzie that's a good one when
you act motherly when you taking care of
someone maan Singh um mosquito nausea
really yeah
[ __ ] us go people mosey mozzie you
just sound like Jonah from Tonga
different accent um cause you're from
Hungary
cause easy cause II it's like cozy cause
II love cause II it's a car Kazi Kazi
Kazi Kazi car seat comfy cozy cozy
context
that's pretty Kazi it's not that I have
a brain I can do the thinking cause II I
think it's when you're riding on a bus
and you're all the way in the back cause
II Ghazis [ __ ] we posted up Gucci
kanji cause II it is a swimming costume
cause II Julius way
in costume cause ego get you cause eat
we're going to the beach do you call it
a swimming costume you personally I've
got a four minute swimming in a swimming
suit Ozzy what do you call it a bathing
suit
oh yeah that causes a baby's a swimming
costume
it's like you don't ask tough to go
sounds costume cause I'm going to work I
need to put on my work costume I love
that you find it more strange that we
call it swimming costume than Kazi yeah
I've been conned esky Esquire wait an
escort oh yeah okay hookers yes birth I
know it's a cooler hello cousin ass come
on I guess that's pretty offensive
Wow really we show a lot of offensive
you know I know that I recently learned
that Eskimo is I think it's raga Tori no
is is s yeah yeah yeah yeah I believe so
yes I know that's the wrong it is yeah
but you guys get the borderline I think
American Eskimo is not a derogatory term
I think he call someone an Eskimo that
might be there are two main I think
anything yeah anything's derogatory if
you make it to raga Tori so if you just
say but that's like same as Simone small
it sounds like a Canuck you know a
Canadian that's on offensive got it but
if you said it real [ __ ] up give my
agrees yeah hope I didn't just defend
like all the industry I don't know
though some of the c-word
and it's a compliment right yeah it's
all about it God knows like my oh you're
[ __ ] sick [ __ ] or you got your
[ __ ] cup
really different it's crazy how like
violated people feel about that word
here oh come on I feel way too blowing
Cruz
oh it is so [ __ ] right he's like it's
a great I really uh you're a sick [ __ ]
yeah you know ever since I tell you I
don't feel as guilty when I say it no
should you you [ __ ] con yeah I like
that you're a bit of a sick cut
yeah you're sick you're sick okay you're
like a real sick man um okay biz oh
there's a it's gotta be like a business
office there's a UH you're working well
um in this business so yeah like we did
some really like sick biz oh okay frizzy
frizzy there's been people like yes
breezy Christmas I'm getting United
right oh um XE XE ex boyfriend a
girlfriend I think it's like yeah exit
no expensive Oh excellent
exit is a good one now yeah like when
you say oh we got to go to the XE no um
and then uh lost on Prezi president
present present what is it is this
president gift she had any good Chrissy
prezzies Jesus a as I swear I swear that
whoever said that verse is like the most
healthy not sick Connie ever yeah
Chrissy brizzy's Chrissy prezzies you
know you've told us some words like
Australian slang that we've tried to use
with other Australians and I've said I
know and I infuriates me so you're not
[ __ ] with your just nice swing is
disagree on a fundamental human level
with those people right because we did
what was it the real Shazza
right how can happen home Australia no
no I think it was freely didn't know
what [ __ ] spiders the came he I didn't I
mean [ __ ] spider yes that's her a super
common one but it's definitely I mean
like Google it's it's like excuse me the
moment she looked at us when we asked
her she she was like with it I was like
mmm
I wish I was then you didn't make me
well no because I think I've actually I
remember weird Australia and you said I
think you said it once and someone who
lived there was like yeah yeah I mean
it's not like I said probably like older
people and she's like around my age and
I don't but I think younger people
probably be like I've never heard that
before them um I've definitely heard
that before and said it too many times
really and Shazza any true Australian
would know what shares Shazza yes gays
are yes Lazar has bad bad as well as I'm
speaking the guys we got to catch up on
Geordie Shore drama talk on noise crazy
[ __ ] I don't have to watch any Geordie
Shore
no I'm you later now on Twitter yeah
yeah yeah it's I'm missing out everyone
Jay from the United States challenge the
challenge on MTV follow me on Twitter
and it's a Jay MTV and I was like no
because it would say JJ father was
Geordie Shore a day I got so excited I
love Jay sure from the challenge yeah
he's amazing by the way yeah yeah he was
with Jenna on the genic hattiesburg last
night her last name
the with the see how do you say your
last name you know I'm talking about
don't look I don't know her last name
oh component you had to wait hang on I
don't know you like he's so hostile
knee-slapper
look look there's a hole in your pants
mmm
let's make a scene about her pants since
you've already made a scene about I
don't do that your pants are really
[ __ ] short my god I wish get like
what get what what are you commanding me
to get because you're taking two ants
down the legs
nope yeah the whole pants okay I feel
violated yeah I mean she's telling to
take my I feel [ __ ] my eyes are
really violating them sighs it's a lot
of like I mean I'm trying to be as
neutral here but that's an Erasmus just
start this whole [ __ ] hangover please
um do you have any more poppers in your
pockets no no I don't want to look at
that this is so this is discriminatory I
don't like how you're treating my pants
is just our rugby players wearing
underwear at that point oh my god stop
looking at my legs all right that was
fun thank god runs here clean all this
up one more thing Oh God um so thank you
for being on the podcast for real yeah
and thanks for doing awesome that I'm
taking care of this one forever and only
get off your dope always the bad guys um
if you want to follow a room full link
are in the description or if you can
remember it's Rome Mackel oh my god stop
you can confuse people
Horo Mackel that exists it's gonna be
like right up there nice they signed up
for all of it that's right
it's actually Rome McIlroy even though
that's not it's just wrong Mackel just
look will link all your links
um but yeah thanks for thanks for
joining us we'll see you guys at VidCon
right you have anything else you want to
ask our friend mom I think she had the
most fun on this popular I always have
fun when really traveling and hanging
out cuz you guys are just like [ __ ]
with each other I just get to sit and
enjoy myself okay over/under for how
many times did I snapchat run down in
this podcast over under or for over I
wear to show once we get six seven seven
you got me seven [ __ ] okay so if I
got you say something one more
oh my god I think it was Joey one two
three four five seven that's not how you
count it's not one two three four five
seven doing six asterisk and I'm putting
the six of you this is a good time now
yeah come back sometime any good if you
want this fun is a fun time well maybe
not any time I'll see you guys at VidCon
it'll be us three the trio what do we
call team legs right later we what are
we cold Indians
yeah we're called Jenna Julianne and the
woman who keeps commenting on Julian's
shorts that's our new team name team led
team likes we are two legs yes oh thanks
you got a minute
oh my god he's that dedicated and uh
guys if you if you want to come up to
Roma and say hi just know that like
she'll probably say hi to you she gets a
little high V so I do get high V with
Julian's room
beware if you want to say how she might
just like freaked out you know I
realized that I was probably yelling the
entire podcast yeah cuz you have your
headphones off
what kind of podcast I mean the core is
that it's our fault we should have
chubby eaten before here yeah she
clearly has never used headphones before
so you you actually have these exact one
no I don't you [ __ ] do I've seen a
[ __ ] die out there my [ __ ] dog I
swear like the healthiest country
that's funny cause it's not a sec honey
it sounds really weird if it doesn't
sound right uh so yeah you have it I
don't know she's literally seen you on a
plane with these I swear on Bowie's life
don't do that I don't I don't [ __ ]
have him anyway on that no I can't and
uh give you a podcast mug on the way out
think no we won't we already gave you
one don't ask for two things that's rude
oh my god Colin loves it though I use it
all the time the mark so good Mike
Collins good guy good Mike he thought
when you get home can you um come over
Jack was right
sorry guys thanks for watching and uh
come back soon it's fun home accent yeah
I'm accent man we'll see you guys at
VidCon this weekend if you're gonna be
there otherwise we'll see you next week
for another podcast whoo Thanks
you